speaking at a pro-abortion rally
yesterday vice president Kamala Harris
accidentally destroyed the left's entire
argument for abortion
Erica is a promise
America is a promise it is a promise
of freedom and liberty
not for some
but for all
[Applause]
a promise we made in the Declaration of
Independence
that we are each endowed
with the right
to liberty and the pursuit of happiness
did you catch the right that she missed
there
Kamala Harris seems to have caught the
right that she missed which is why I
think she stumbled she said you know a
lesson Declaration of Independence says
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal and
earned out by their creator with certain
unalienable rights among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness excuse me what'd you just say
Kamala oh I said I said Liberty now
before that oh and I said um
the uh The Pursuit of Happiness now I
was a little bit before that one I said
yeah uh our creator in Dallas with uh
right to it liberty and the pursuit of
happy I heard something on the cough
what was the I think it was right it was
the right to life
because
you can't pursue happiness without
Liberty and you can't have Liberty
without life in fact you can't have or
do anything at all without life which is
why life is not merely one right among
many but the fundamental right upon
which all the others rest a fact so
obvious a truth so clear that even
Kamala Harris had to stumble upon it I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Jeremy Bertram
who says my tin foil hat protected me
from myocarditis it did it was actually
uh a far better medical precaution I
think a far more effective one than
those vaccines that everybody took
really good stuff man those doctors
should start prescribing tin foil hats
amazing how much they can protect your
health now when you want to protect your
wealth you got to check out Birch gold
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98 the
current administration's New Year's
goals are to tax spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation if this is at odds with
your goals and you are tired of the
government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
crashes now you can own gold in a tax
sheltered retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA in Precious Metals text
Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98 98 to claim
your free info kit on gold then talk to
one of their precious metal Specialists
with an A plus rating with a Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings right now text
Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s to 98 98 98 protect
yourself with gold today that is Knowles
Canada w l e s to 98.98
98 today
speaking of Rights Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis has just launched
a heinous
incomprehensible attack
on children's right to learn about weird
queer Theory sex stuff in a in a black
studies course and ideologically
left-wing activist course in high school
can you imagine
this course on black history what are
one what's one of the lessons about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards we believe in teaching
kids uh facts and how to think but we
don't believe they should have an agenda
imposed on them when you try to use
black history to shoehorn in queer
Theory uh you are clearly trying to use
that for political purposes
Ron DeSantis is doing exactly the right
thing here this is great that he is
Banning this black studies course
frankly even if it weren't teaching
queer Theory as part of it he still
should have banned the course because
black studies African-American studies
it's not just a regular old history
course
it's not a regular old cultural history
or military history or any serious study
of history it is a derivation of
critical theory and it is essentially
just leftist radical political activism
that's true of pretty much all of the
studies departments all of the gay
studies women's studies
black studies all of the studies
departments that cropped up in the
second half of the 20th century they're
just radical leftism okay and they're
academically not rigorous at all and
they poison people's minds and turns
their brains to soup so it's good that
this is being kicked out of the high
schools
however
[Music]
the argument that Ron DeSantis is making
here is not totally right it might be
politically effective so I don't
begrudge him that but it's not totally
right
now one thing that's great Rhonda Santos
used to say we don't want to teach
students what to think only how to think
and you'll notice in that speech there
because I I have
tried to correct that point a little bit
before and I think some other
conservatives may have too and you
notice he changed it a little bit he
said we wanted to teach students facts
and how to think that's an important
correction because if that's not the
same as saying we want to teach them how
to think not what to think when you say
we want to teach students facts you're
saying we do want to teach students what
to think and by teaching students what
to think about certain facts about
certain things then we are thereby
teaching the students how to think
but the point that DeSantis made is
all of this is what education is about
education is not about pushing a
political agenda and in fact DeSantis
when he posted that clip he tweeted that
as well he said this isn't we do not
think that education should be about
pushing a political agenda
that might be an effective piece of
political rhetoric but it isn't true
and we should we should all at least be
aware that education is in fact about
pushing a political agenda that is the
point of public education
public and political mean the exact same
thing
political is another word for public
it's the stuff that we all do together
not in our little private lives not in
the recesses of our own mind but
together
so when when DeSantis says education is
about pursuing truth not about a
political agenda he is half right it is
about pursuing truth but it is also
about applying those truths to the
political situation education is about
creating citizens education is about
inculcating a Civic spirit in people
education is about creating the next
generation of Americans who are going to
build up our country and live together
education is how we are raised and the
question of how we are raised and how we
behave and what we believe and how we
view our fellow countrymen and how we
view our country that is a deeply
political question
so the
it is perfectly right and just to ban
black studies or whatever other critical
theory derived courses that have somehow
seeped their way like a gaseous poison
into High School classrooms it is
perfectly good to ban them for political
reasons they teach things that are not
true
and also they have poisonous political
effects and the only reason that the
libs want to put those courses into the
High School classrooms is because they
know that education is political the
libs are are right about so many things
at least in the abstract they get a lot
of things right in the abstract they get
they get pretty much all those things
wrong in practice when you get into the
specifics and into the substance but in
terms of the abstract and the procedure
in the form they tend to get these
things right they recognize that there's
no such thing as total Free Speech they
recognize that all cultures have
standards and Norms conservatives
pretended that that wasn't the case for
the last 50 years that's how we lost our
American notion of free speech the libs
know that education is political
the conservatives pretended it's not
political that's how conservatives lost
the entire educational apparatus in
America
the the libs they're very crafty they're
very clever they have terrible
prescriptions for America and for other
countries as well but but they are
clever about how politics works and so
I think DeSantis is doing a great job I
don't even begrudge him his
slightly imprecise political rhetoric
here but at the very least we
conservatives we people who are
applauding the santis in this phenomenal
action we should not be deceived he's
not trying to deceive us but we should
not deceive ourselves
education is political it is good that
it is political we should pursue
political ends that are conducive to to
truth and Justice not that they're
antithetical to those things they are
they go perfectly along with truth and
justice but we should pursue those
things in the classroom because if we
don't do it somebody else will and if
it's the libs who are pursuing their
political agenda in the classroom I
promise you it is not going to to go
along with truth and Justice and
certainly not with the American way the
lives are Furious about what DeSantis is
doing kjp Kareem Jean-Pierre the White
House Press Secretary says the move is
incomprehensible
these types of actions aren't new
they're not new from from what we're
seeing especially from Florida sadly
Florida currently bans teachers from
taking to talking about who they are and
who they love as we've talked about many
times here in this briefing room they
have banned more books in schools and
libraries than almost every other state
in the country and let's not forget they
didn't ban they didn't block be more
clear I want to make sure I'm using the
right word here they didn't block AP
European History they didn't block our
music history they didn't block our art
history but the state chooses to to
block a course that is meant for high
achieving high school students to learn
about their history of arts and culture
and it is uh you know it is uh
incomprehensible again and I will just
leave it there leave it there to make
your own uh to make your own
determination of why this occurred and
why this happened again it is not our
place to to direct or to to be involved
in any local school curriculum but this
is concerning oh it's not your place
okay then quiet
how about we just close that old Yap up
there at the White House Press breeding
room and listen it's after that 10
minute monologue I just launched into I
just want to make clear it's not my
place to to weigh in on this
but I'm going to continue to weigh in on
it as well incomprehensible the only
thing that's incomprehensible is the
course
and and the way that the libs are
portraying this that this is about
teaching the history of black people
it's not that's just a complete lie the
course includes books such as Kimberly
crenshaw's mapping the margins
intersectionality identity politics and
violence against women of color
that's not hey what did Frederick
Douglass do that is pushing a radical
Marxist
neo-marxist cultural Marxist whatever
term you want to use to describe the
20th century uh tradition of Western
Marxism that's what it's pushing okay
intersectionality the case for
reparations by Tony he's he goes
tanahisi codes is a leftist pop writer
he's not a historian he is not a scholar
he is not someone who deserves even one
seconds time in in a high school
classroom he is a radical and glib
magazine essayist there's a section on
black queer studies as Ron DeSantis said
that is what is incomprehensible and
that is what is going to muddle up
students Minds there's this idea in our
society that we need to have a totally
open classroom don't ban anything just
be open to all ideas well that's crazy
you have to you have to ban certain
ideas you have to leave them out of the
curriculum there are only so many weeks
in a semester
every second that you waste reading Tony
easy coats and Kimberly Rancho is a
second that you're not reading a real
historian that you're not reading I
don't know Shakespeare that you're
you're not reading Tolstoy you're not
reading writers who are valuable who
will edify you and who will make you
more educated every every second that
you waste in a math classroom being
taught that two plus two equals five is
the second that you're not being taught
the truth which is that two plus two
equals four we have to ban two plus two
equals five out of the classroom
and we need to limit our curricula to
things that will actually educate
students and I promise you Kimberly
Crenshaw will not
speaking of
Banning things in the classroom Stephen
King
the pop novelist
he just tweeted out he said
hey kids it's your old buddy Steve King
here telling you that if they ban a book
in your school haul your ass to the
nearest bookstore or Library ASAP
and find out what they don't want you to
read
but they who are they I don't know if
they
Ron DeSantis
who's that he sounds like Kanye over
here who who's they though who is they
well it depends who they is I guess
because I know this is a very popular
opinion
is the opinion don't ban any books if
there's a Banned Book we need to go read
it immediately
well it depends what the book is and it
depends who does the Banning
if the Banning is being done by bad
people
who who are not going to help you become
educated then I guess you should go read
the book
if the book is being banned by just and
wise and prudent authorities then maybe
don't read the book
depends what the book is if the book is
Hamlet
then you should go read the book if the
book is
gay porn as is turning up in lots of
schools then don't read the book
if it's pornography of any kind don't
read the book
you will not be edified by that you will
not be educated by that
what is Stephen King suggesting all
books with genderqueer by Maya kababi we
should read that
maybe I don't know Mein Kampf should my
listen they don't want to teach you mind
conference schools you better go out
there you're in sixth grade you better
go read mineconf is that what he's
saying no I don't think I mean even if
you're going to read mind comp is a sort
of historical
uh study maybe wait until you're I don't
know like 16 17 maybe I don't think does
anyone really think that's appropriate
for a child
I don't I don't think so I think there
are plenty of books that are not
appropriate for a child
I think uh Ulysses by James Joyce I
don't know do we really that's something
we have to read no of course not of
course it's it's a very shallow and glib
and liberal and modern idea that you
should never ban or suppress any book
it is it is an idea that is completely
out of keeping with the entire Western
tradition
Catholics Protestants
ancients
even many secularists everyone agrees
that certain books should not be taught
you see book burning in the Old
Testament Plato argued for the burning
of a a rival's books
Martin Luther I often point out on the
show being Catholic Martin Luther is not
like my number one guy you know Martin
Luther argued to burn
certain books but plenty of Catholic
writers have argued the Vatican has a
list of banned books
we unnaturally have ban certain books
the Liberals banned books they banned
the Bible in classrooms conservatives
used to ban books like gay porn in the
classrooms everybody recognizes you need
to in order to be educated you need
certain limits that's the whole point of
education is to Tamp down your appetites
and to cultivate your rational will and
virtue speaking of schools
well actually you know what before we
get to schools there's this this will
tie in in a second I'd like to get to an
important cultural matter speaking of
limits and standards
M MS
M Ms has just made a major announcement
it has retired its spokes candies and
hired
a new spokeslady
Eminem's tweets at America let's talk
then last year we've made some changes
to our beloved spokes candies we weren't
sure if anyone would even notice and we
definitely didn't think it would break
the internet but now we get it
even a Candy's shoes can be polarizing
which was the last thing Eminem's wanted
since we're all about bringing people
together
therefore we've decided to take an
indefinite pause from the spokes candies
in their place we are proud to introduce
a spokesperson America can agree on the
Beloved Maya Rudolph we're confident Ms
Rudolph Will Champion the power of fun
to create a world where everyone feels
they belong
I like Maya Rudolph
very funny lady I think she was friends
with Norm Macdonald that's really all
you need for me to have respect for you
I want to be perfectly clear
Eminem's marketing problems will not go
away
until they bring back the sexy green m m
until that green m m is sexy again
it's not going to go away I'm not saying
this to be provocative I'm not saying
this as a threat I am simply observing
that fact
you may recall last year Eminem's
decided to take all the fun little
differentiating factors about all the
little M M's characters and do what our
culture is doing to everybody and try to
make them all kind of uniform and
androgynous
and so they turned the green Eminem Who
had previously been a sexy little
trollop of an m m and turned her into a
kind of uh tomboyish
androgynous gender-neutral candy
and there was a lot of backlash to this
and the libs made fun of us I think
Tucker had a real field day with the
whole green m m sexy thing but the libs
made fun of us they said well you
weirdos why do you care about a sexy m m
because it's a symbol
no I don't think that there are very
many people out there who are lusting
over the m m but it is perfectly
rational to be concerned that Eminem's
is making the m m less sexy because the
m m is a symbol it's a symbol of the way
that we are viewing women in our culture
and that's what people have problems
with we have problems that we're
chopping off the breasts of teenage
girls and we're forcing men forcing
women rather to change with men in their
locker rooms
and we're now posting Billboards not of
beautiful models to be surrounded by
images of beauty even if they're
somewhat idealized through Photoshop and
lighting and special effects but now
we're intentionally posting grotesque
pictures and grotesqueries all over
our culture not even just in terms of
models but in terms of all Aesthetics
that's what people are concerned about
we're concerned that we now have a
culture that is forcing us to live
according to lies and forcing us to call
good evil and Truth falsehood and Beauty
ugliness that's what we're concerned
about and Eminem's is doing nothing to
solve that problem they're saying whoa
whoa whoa we didn't expect a backlash
because we we took the stilettos off the
candy whoa okay well to correct that
we're just going to get rid of it
entirely no we don't want that either
that's it's such an annoying fact about
our culture it's such an annoying
response these days which is
you have a traditional thing
and then you have the liberal agitation
to get rid of the traditional thing and
then the culture caves to the liberal
agitation
then you have backlash from the
conservatives and then they just get rid
of the thing altogether I remember this
I was in college I was on freshman
student government in college
and in college we were going to have a
freshman dance and so we decided it was
going to be Gone With the Wind theme
because our class president that year
was a southern guy and it'd be nice you
wear fun costumes or whatever and then
as always it's like liberal white kids
saying this is very offensive to black
people not to me and no black people are
complaining but it's offensive I'm
offended on behalf of the black people
and
so what happened was the the school
didn't the student government we didn't
stick to our guns
we didn't come up with some new
interesting idea we just got rid of the
theme I think the theme ended up being
the color blue or something and that's
what our culture does it always just
goes down to the absolute lowest common
denominator so that we get rid of all
these fun little ornate things that that
Define our very culture we say okay
we're gonna get rid of that we'll just
have a regular spokesman like all the
other companies okay that's fine no it's
not fine come on guys
I want things that are ornate I want
things that are specific and eccentric
and traditional I want
the sexy green Eminem
that's what I want speaking of schools
and women who are known for being sexy
Kim Kardashian just spoke at Harvard
Business School
this has caused a major stir
someone suggested they said Kim
Kardashian speaking at Harvard Business
School well there goes all of Harvard's
Prestige and I thought Harvard's
prestige
the the most impressive
Harvard students are the ones who drop
out
Harvard's Prestige Bill Gates
Mark Zuckerberg the list goes on and
they're the ones that drop out Harvard's
prestige
Harvard's Prestige one of the most
famous Harvard students
I think a graduate to Harvard I believe
he actually graduated
one of one of the most impressive
Harvard students in recent years is the
Unabomber
Harvard's Prestige Harvard's lucky to
have Kim Kardashian however it actually
is lucky to have Kim Kardashian
especially at the business school
because she was there to talk about her
shapewear company skims
put a pause right there what is a
shapewear company I don't know whether I
assume it's a clothing kind of company
shapewear that's very strange
uh they they uh listened at this school
to a two-hour lecture
as part of a direct to Consumer seminar
uh Kim Kardashian is a co-founder of
this company skims
it's a multi-billion dollar company uh
it launched a private Equity Firm called
Sky Partners uh
uh skims recently doubled its valuation
from 1.6 billion to 3.2 billion over a
period of just nine months as investors
rushed to acquire equity in that company
then Kim goes on launches this private
Equity company I don't know she's pretty
impressive to me
at least by the standard of Business
School
I don't know that Kim Kardashian has
read a lot of old poetry or Greek
philosophy or anything like that
but the woman knows a thing or two about
business
and there's a big difference between a
liberal arts education which is what a
lot of people seek for an undergraduate
education and a business school
education or a law school education or a
medical school education those are those
are trades that's a vocational training
to learn a job
so I agree it would probably be
inappropriate for Kim Kardashian who is
famous for
she's famous for showing off her body on
camera and then having a reality TV show
launched from that
it would be probably inappropriate for
her to go lecture on
Dostoyevsky or something on Aristotle at
Harvard undergraduate but in terms of
business school yeah she's she's one of
the most successful businessmen in the
country
and and business school is largely a
farce including Harvard Business School
including all the all the really
prominent Business Schools the purpose
of business school is not to really
educate yourself all that much it's
mostly for networking it can be a
credential if you want to move up the
management hierarchy but if you want to
be an entrepreneur and launch your own
business it's really the whole point of
it is just networking you don't
you don't need to actually do that much
in terms of scholarly rigor to be in
business school and I just I find it I
hate to take Kim Kardashian's side in
almost any matter but
it it's just so
absurdly
elitist it's so baselessly elitist
for anyone to suggest oh Kim Kardashian
she has no right to to lecture at this
school what are you Kim Kardashian is
more successful than any of the people
that she is lecturing will ever be in
terms of business Acumen and business
success I would be willing to bet a
significant amount of money that not one
person in that lecture hall will ever
make more money or be more successful in
business than Kim Kardashian business
school like so much of our higher
education structure these days is pretty
much a joke actually here's the proof
there's an amazing story just came out
yesterday from Wharton School of
Business Wharton is arguably the best
business school in the country Harvard
is also up there but but Wharton out of
UPenn is one of the very top schools in
the country
and chat GPT
which is an AI program I just did very
well on some Wharton business school
exams
this is a mass-market artificial
intelligence chat bot it was launched by
open AI I've played around on it I'm
sure a lot of other people have played
around on this on this software as well
well a research paper from Wharton from
this professor Christian turves said
that chat gbt earned a grade between a b
and a B minus on a final exam that is
usually presented to MBA students
what does this mean
this I mean it's kind of funny and maybe
it shows you the business school isn't
all that hard and maybe it shows you
that artificial intelligence is really
impressive
the most important thing this tells you
is that
the current line about artificial
intelligence is backwards the current
line about artificial intelligence is
that AI is going to replace all those
those useless low-skilled workers this
is what you hear from from people like
Yuval Harare or some of the world
economic foreign types that say oh you
know we're going to have all these
useless people in the future because of
Automation and so we'll just apply them
with drugs and video games and
usually what they mean by usage people
the poor people the uneducated people
the service worker type people they're
going to be replaced by automation
chat GPT Wharton business school is
showing it's the opposite
the useless people
are the white-collar workers in most
cases
not not not all of them but a lot of
them chat CPT shows quote a remarkable
ability to automate some of the skills
of Highly compensated knowledge workers
in general and specifically the
knowledge workers in the jobs held by
MBA graduates it does an amazing job at
basic operations management and process
analysis questions including those that
are based on case studies not only are
the answers correct but the explanations
are excellent
right
it's it is true that at McDonald's now
sometimes there will be fewer workers
because you can place your orders on
machines
but you still have workers there
okay and McDonald's is one of the the
most automated of any restaurant chain
when you go out to a restaurant where
you actually want a dining experience
that is always going to have people
involved in it
because people augment that experience
you want the waiter to come over in the
nice coat with the tie and say Mr so and
so can I get you a drink oh I recommend
having the pasta with the steak or you
want that Human Experience that's that's
part of what makes going out to dinner
special
you don't want Thelma to come over thumb
of the robot to say beep boop Martini or
Manhattan beep beep you know just starts
frying and that's that wouldn't be fun
and special
you you want that human contact you were
going to want you even as robots become
more common in our homes you're still
going to want people with their judgment
with that human touch with their
artistic ability to go in and operate
certain certain aspects of a service
economy
I'm not sure that you need any human
beings to operate most of business and
management and white collar jobs
the people who should be really afraid
here
are all those white collar laptop
workers all the ones who tell the the
poor Rust Belt Americans who whose
politicians betrayed them and who
shipped their jobs overseas the the ones
who say well just learn to code keep up
yeah the ones we're going to need to
learn to code are going to be largely
white-collar workers and they're never
going to learn to code better than chat
GPT so I don't know maybe it's time to
learn to plumb
time to learn to install electrical
wires
and to learn time to learn a useful
trade I would suggest speaking of
white-collar jobs
yet another person
has strongly intimated
that she will throw her hat in the ring
for the most prestigious white collar
job of all
president of the United States that
person would be Nikki Haley are you
going to run for president well I'm not
going to make an announcement here but
when you're looking at a run for
president you look at two things you
first look at does the current situation
push for new leadership
the second question is
am I that person that could be that new
leader yes we need to go in a New
Direction and can I be that leader yes I
think I can be that leader I was as
Governor I took on a hurting state with
double-digit unemployment and we made it
the Beast of the southeast as Ambassador
you know I took on the world when they
tried to disrespect us and I think I
showed what I'm capable of at the United
Nations so do I think I could be that
leader yes but we are still working
through things and we'll figure it out
I've never lost a race I said that then
I'd still say that now I'm not going to
lose now but stay tuned it sounds like
you're close it sounds are we getting to
the exploratory committee stage here I
think stay tuned
okay so yes is the answer barring some
horrible polling that Nikki receives
showing that she's at the complete
bottom of the deck uh this is a woman
who is planning to run for president in
2024. and there's there's one thing
holding it up
or one one thing complicating her
announcement which is that Nikki Haley
has previously said that she would not
run for president in 2024 if Trump runs
she said she wouldn't run it from bronze
that she's behind Trump she supports
Trump and this was complicated because
she made those comments after she had
uh criticized Trump in the press and
criticized Trump after January 6 and all
the rest of it and that's complicated
because
Nikki Haley made those criticisms after
she had been a loyal Trump Defender she
was one of the most prominent loyal
Trump officials during the
administration she was at the U.N which
is a great job she did a great job in
the job but it's a really great job if
you want to raise your public profile
because your whole job is to stand up
against the worst people in the world
every single day and you hold your hand
up and you say I'm gonna Stick It To You
China or North Korea or wherever
so that was complicated and then I was
complicated because she had been
somewhat critical of trump before he
became president so
there had been a kind of
ambiguity to exactly which lane Nikki
Haley was going to run in there was a
world in which Nikki Haley could have
run in the Trump Lane had Trump not run
for president
even though Nikki Haley is
probably more moderate than Donald Trump
don't forget Donald Trump had a fairly
moderate political record before he
became president so he moved a little
bit a lot more in the conservative
direction as well Nikki Haley had a
relatively moderate Republican record as
governor of South Carolina then she was
more in the Trump Direction and now I
think what this tells you the fact that
she is going full speed ahead is that
Nikki Haley is looking to run probably
more in the moderate Lane in 2024.
Trump's got the Trump Lane
DeSantis is running in the
really I guess to the right of Donald
Trump specifically to the right of trump
on kovid specifically to the right of
Donald Trump on the vaccines
and then roughly in the same place as
Donald Trump on every other issue and
then you've got
Nikki Haley I think staking out the
moderate ground and you know we all
knocked the moderates and and regularly
you know call for people to go further
to the right of Attila the Hun but this
is the Republican Party there's a huge
moderate faction of the Republican party
and right now Nikki Haley is the top
candidate in that faction I can't think
of another person I know that John
Kasich has suggested maybe he wants to
run in that or there there have been
Larry Hogan who's a moderate governor of
Maryland thinks that he wants to run in
that lane and there are there are some
other people as well but right now I
think Nikki Haley is probably the top
the topic what it also tells you is
Nikki does not believe that Trump is
going to clear the field the argument
for Trump even announcing as early as he
did was that Trump's announcement would
clear the field of candidates because
Trump was was so potent a force in the
GOP but his poll numbers if you One
Believes polls have have remained where
they were or declined actually a little
bit and so the political effect of that
is it hasn't cleared the field Rhonda
Santos is for all intents and purposes
running for president right now there
are other people waiting in the wings
Tim Scott has suggested he might run
Mike Pompeo suggested he might run uh
Mike Pence looks like he's going to run
Mike Pence also might try to run a
little bit more in that moderate Lane
for president but because of the way
that his relationship ended with Trump
his political numbers are just not that
great right now so I think Nikki Haley
thinks she could probably beat him in
that lane so all of which tells you that
unless something dramatically changes
for Trump he might still get the
nomination he might still win the
presidency
there is going to be a primary
unless something radical changes today
there will be a primary there's another
it's another really important
caveat to all of this or additional
detail rather which is that another
woman wants to run for president that
would be
Governor Christie known in South Dakota
I think all of us can agree As Americans
that China shouldn't be buying up land
in the United States that there are
enemy they're an evil government
built on communism and taking away
freedom and that that isn't something we
should allow to have a presence here in
our great country this is an issue that
came up you know months ago when we saw
a land purchase in North Dakota our
neighbors to the north that a Chinese
entity bought up land next to their Air
Force Base saying they were going to
build a corn plant but there wasn't
enough even corn grown in that area to
sustain a facility like that and it
became under question I think we all
agree that that we shouldn't allow our
enemies to have a presence especially
close to our national security
infrastructure we have Ellsworth Air
Force Base which is going to be the home
of the b-21s we want to make sure that
those who have the chance to purchase
our land here in our state love America
and that they want to do good not do us
harm
so Christy know I'm saying she wants to
restrict land purchases by the Chinese
you might remember this story because
Ron DeSantis announced that a week or
two ago what does this tell you
Christine um wants to run for president
I think she's made that perfectly clear
over the last two years and
Christy gnome is going to run in the
Rhonda santis Lane
so Ron DeSantis here leading among the
governors there's no question Ron
DeSantis is the leader and everyone else
is following suit
uh Christy gnome thinks she's going to
take on that lane then you've got Nikki
Haley and maybe Mike Pence and maybe Tim
Scott running in the the somewhat more
moderate Lane and you've got Trump out
here they all think that Trump is
relatively weak and can be beaten but
Trump is also running because Trump and
Haley and DeSantis and gnome and Pence
and everybody else all these Republicans
who want to run in 2024 they're looking
up at the White House they're looking at
Biden saying this guy is weak this guy
can be beat and I think we all agree
with that
Jeremy's razors
suffering a great deal that ends very
soon forty percent off all razors why
the discount I'm glad you asked a year
ago when Joe Biden tried to force a
vaccine mandate on private employers and
some 85 million Americans the daily wire
told him where to stick it okay we sued
the federal government we won after a
6-3 ruling in our favor from the Supreme
Court the Mandate was dead
deader than disco so on the first
anniversary of this tremendous victory
for all Americans the daily wire CEO and
God King Jeremy boring has issued a
special decree on the razors that bear
his name right now and only for a
limited time all Germans razors are 40
off that's right 40 4-0 off that means
you can get a kit with a Precision 5
razor and flip back trim or shave cream
post shave bomb extra blades and a handy
travel case for just 35.99
it's a savings of twenty four dollars
get forty percent off Jeremy's razors
before the deal Ends by going to
jeremy'sraisers.com also the greatest
interview show on the internet
has turned into the greatest party game
and it's available for pre-order now
it's backed by popular demand after
selling out for Christmas the yes or no
game
is compelling
conspiratorial everything you need to
have a good time deliberate the greatest
ales of modern society from feminism
seed oils the new world order to trans
ideology daytime TV and the portal to
hell in your pocket known as your cell
phone but it's not just a game it's the
ultimate test of your character do you
really know your parents your friends
your significant other or the people
around you actually who they purport to
be the suspense is eating away at you
already isn't it you need answers so
what are you waiting for secure your
copy before it sells out again it is
going to sell out again we we sold
through the first thousand
boxes of this game instantly and we
don't we we have a few thousand three or
four thousand that we've ordered now
they they are going to sell out uh so
head on over to dailywire.com shop to
pre-order your copy yes or no 600 have
already oh wow 600 have already been
pre-ordered I think we've done like one
read for this so go head over pre-order
it now
and now
I'm gonna take your calls on this show
let's take it away with who do we have
let's take it away with
Alex from Taiwan Alex you're on the air
hello Michael can you hear me I can hear
you Alex what time is it in Taiwan right
now
is 11 10 at night I stayed up for you
last night but you didn't want to take
my call Alex thank you for staying up
over in Taiwan I appreciate it that's
maybe you've had a couple of coca-colas
maybe you're more relaxed maybe I should
start doing my show at 11 o'clock
Central I don't know how can I help you
I won't mind so it's more that I can
help you you mentioned last week that
you are a huge Elvis Presley fan and I
just wanted to let you know one of the
secrets of Israel you're both a staunch
Catholic and you want to probably go to
the holy land at some point or return
there if you've already been and so uh
the last time I went I found out that
there is an Elvis Presley Cafe just west
of Jerusalem outside of it the Builder
decided that a lot of Kings had come
through the city but uh the king of
Rocket never got his chance and so he
created a giant golden statue of Elvis
Presley If you go inside of the cafe you
can play about 35 shekels and they give
you a mug with coffee in it and you get
to keep the mug and on the mug is a
picture of Elvis and a couple other
things and so I just want to let you
know that the next time you go there you
can kill two birds with one stone Alex
that is amazing in in a city that is
really for the King of Kings and the
Lord of lords a uh in the holy land
where many kings traveled from all over
the world to see the King of Kings it it
certainly makes sense that the king of
rock and roll would join the Magi and so
so many other of the terrestrial royalty
to uh come on over and visit the Holy
Land thank you Alex thank you for that
advice I look forward to to visiting the
Elvis Cafe next time I hope it's not a
kind of golden idol of Elvis that would
be unfortunate but as long as it's uh
merely an object of admiration or
veneration rather than than worship I
think that's that's a wonderful thing
okay
let's turn to Jake from South Florida
Jake you're on the air
hey Michael I had a question about
marriage so you often talk about how the
left tries to redefine terms uh and
specifically the word marriage but I
guess uh to me it seems at least that
the left successfully has redefined that
word and at what point do you accept the
fact that it is no longer like you know
a union between men and women in the
common cultural under understanding
really is you know just what people do
when they love each other and realize
that you might be holding on to an old
definition of marriage much like someone
might be saying well you know in the
1940s a computer was someone who did
calculations and people might just say
well that doesn't make sense anymore the
answer is you never accept the new
definition of marriage and you you never
accept it not because I don't not
because you are an old fuddy daddy or
not because you're stuck in the past not
because you hate gay people or anything
that's one of the most Preposterous
accusations that we get especially that
I get you know I'm from New York I went
to the gayest university in the United
States if not the world I lived in Los
Angeles surrounded by a bunch of Show
Business weirdos a disproportionate
number of my friends have had homosexual
inclinations okay but no matter how much
you love your gay cousin or or whoever
else in your life you can never accept
the new definition of marriage because
marriage is not up for redefinition
certain things can be up for
redefinition
things that are merely socially
constructed uh Fashions fashion is a
perfect example of this a male fashion
has changed dramatically over times
several centuries ago men wore frilly
sorts of coats and high heels now men
don't do that fashion has been redefined
for men and for women but the the
reality of men and women the fundamental
reality and the union between a man and
a woman that we call marriage cannot be
redefined because marriage is not
socially constructed but rather is a
natural institution and the reason
reason that marriage is a natural
institution is because as Aristotle says
and as Saint Thomas Aquinas kind of
baptizing Aristotle or explicating
Aristotle points out a man is a social
being man is not as the Liberals would
have us believe man is not just floating
as an individual atom in space
completely undifferentiated and and
we're all just the same and and a woman
is is no different than a man and a man
no different than a woman and no that's
not really how it is man is a social
being we find our identity in society
with one another
and there is a distinction in human
nature between men and women because men
and women are not indiscernible and
indistinguishable but are in fact
complementary and so because man is a
social being because we have a distinct
sexual natures and because man is a
coupling being man is naturally drawn to
couple with a woman physically and and
spiritually as well and then the product
of that Union is a new human being so so
uh fundamental is that to human nature
then you simply cannot redefine marriage
we can pretend all we want all day but
but that's not going to do anything even
even if we remain confused for decades
even if we remain confused in certain
countries for a century or two marriage
will endure because it is it is uh part
of natural law and it's part of man
man's very nature in his in his own
desire and self-understanding okay
before we go let's take another question
on uh from Anthony in Alabama Anthony uh
you were on the air from the state that
that houses my absolute favorite city in
America
what was that what what city is that
well that would be Mobile Alabama I've
just always loved mobile I tell sweet
little Elisa that we're going to retire
there someday she's never been but it's
just very Charming City so Anthony
what's on your mind
it'd be great to have you Michael okay
um I've been a fan for about two years I
want to first thank you for your
Catholic faith and conservative ideas
that have shaped me I'm going to the
University of Alabama next year I'm
interested in politics and possibly
going to get a degree in philosophy uh
thanks to you
um encouraging that
um and maybe a law degree depending on
how things go other than starting my
club name cigars and politics what
should I involve myself in to uh kind of
dabble in to see what I should maybe you
know do in life I guess is what I'm
saying I love that club I too started a
cigar club in college it was called the
society for intellectual growth and
reinvigoration or cigar and it was just
a front to get the school to pay for my
cigar habit for me and my buddies so
that's great I think that will be very
edifying for you and and I think it will
be not only because cigars are tasty and
it's kind of a fun thing to do and as
far as vices go I think it's you know
relatively quite Innocent but also
because one of the best things you can
do in college
is stay up late
uh hopefully not over too many drinks
you know over an okay number of drinks
but you don't want to be completely out
of your mind because you stay up late
over cigars which sharpen your mind
because of the nicotine and because of
the relaxation that comes from that and
you just debate all sorts of matters
with your friends and that that's going
to provide you at least in my experience
it did uh provide you as good an
education probably a much better
education than what you're going to get
in the classrooms what else can you
involve yourself in
I would recommend if you if you want to
maintain a tie to the school whether for
networking or friendship or both you
should involve yourself in one somewhat
established institution I did that I'm a
member of a one of the conservative
debating societies from my college and
and it was just it's just a wonderful
group and it's it's really my main tie
left to the the university
um so that's a great thing to do and
then in terms of setting yourself up for
a job again don't forget you're not at
the school you're studying philosophy so
you could go to law school later that's
a trade school you go to business school
later that's a trade school
get on the job training okay good you're
learning your trade
but you're you're studying in college to
cultivate your soul
and to to uh
to not study something that is going to
directly get you a job so you got to
take care of the job stuff
separately for me if you want to go into
politics for me the best training I got
was working on a political campaign
between my sophomore and junior year and
then into my junior year
that was a very very
uh effective training ground for what I
now work in which is politics and and
political media even specifically uh so
I would do that you you do that through
your internships you do that even maybe
off campus a little bit that can
distinguish you to employers that'll
give you that training that will then
complement the intellectual and
spiritual work that you've done in your
liberal education thank you for calling
in we are going to take one or two more
callers over in the member block but we
got to go to the member block okay the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Knowles
Canada wlas at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
we'll see you in the member block
[Music]